[Música]
[Aplausos]
boa noite meu nome é carlos eduardo na
verdade nós aprender cada dos anjos e
hoje em dia estou vivendo um sonho
coletivo e comunitário
meu pai se mudou para belo horizonte em
83 e ele veio de uma cidade ribeirinha
do rio são francisco perto da bahia e
minas gerais mesmo que ele trouxe um
pouco da cultura na roça da cama da
folia de reis
minha mãe na mesma época também veio
para belo horizonte vindo da zona da
mata perto do rio de janeiro do sul
aquela história da família italiana que
ficou pobre e tal
e ela veio para ser doméstica e babá
eles se encontrarem 85 no parque
municipal fizeram essas coisas que
adolescente faz quando se encontra um
parque municipal e em 86 nasceu minha
irmã carol 87 meu irmão pedro e eu nasci
em 90 era uma família muito bonita muito
unida e feliz e o povo ficava falando
que a gente parecia filho de rico
talvez por ser branquinho olhão claro
arregalado e pelo contrário a gente não
era nada rico gente tirava vivia numa
vila que parecia vila do chaves e lá a
gente não chegou a passar necessidade
por conta do empreendedorismo dos meus
pais e minha mãe durante o dia vendia
sutiã monta power r focava com as amigas
meu pai era taxista já não era mais
mecânico e no momento ele era taxista
não tinha uber ainda e ele momento era
motorista particular
só que a noite eles vêm de um cachorro
quente que era maravilhoso gostoso
demais famoso até hoje no santa efigênia
e eles tinham como sonhar por conta do
empreendedorismo
então em 95 meu pai comprou um terreno
que comprou não mentira ele trocou num
fusca e numa tv num terreno numa
ocupação aos pés da vila cafezal que era
a vila mais bala
dados mais perigosas da cidade né minha
mãe falava eu não vou mudar pra favela
de jeito nenhum ser louco você comprou
um barranco realmente era um barranco
gente era mais ou menos assim o juro
juro e meu pai ele não é engenheiro não
é arquiteto e ele falou assim não presta
atenção
papai vai cortar o barranco aqui pois o
papai quarto barranca aqui retira esse
barranco
papai vai construir uma casinha aqui
depois outra casinha depois outro caso
uma casa em cima do barranco e ele
desenhava essa casa gente
esse é o desenho e essa minha casa então
barulho do meu pai porque ele escolar
show eles que achou muito e ali eu
aprendia a cultura do puxadinho a
cultura da gambiarra mas principalmente
a cultura do pecfaz que é o que move a
comunidade beleza estava ali crianção
nessa comunidade
cheio de energia cheio do fogo do
espírito santo dentro do meu corpo e eu
amava rua amava muito a rua e eu não
gostava da escola a escola era fileiras
uniforme apito para entrar apito passar
'cala boca olha pra frente isso não
entrava na minha cabeça e nos projetos
sociais que tinha quebrado eu tinha
oportunidades
esses projetos eram maravilhosos porque
aprendi muito sobre cultura aprende
violão um inglês musicalidade em geral
teatro e muito esporte futebol natação
tênis basquete vôlei
ali também eu aprendia a agradecer pelo
alimento isso é muito importante para a
concepção da comunidade em comunidade
também o aprendizado em roda a gente
tinha o respeito comunitário um pelo
outro e
nesse momento eu falei 'não quero ser
escola fileira carteira material de
trabalho nem lápis borracha
eu queria ser criativo e com 14 anos de
idade eu falei pô sou artista
jogava se gosta eu gostava de rimar e
aliada à cultura hip hop
comecei a escrever meus versos com 14
anos tive uma carreira de rap bem legal
lancei dois discos solo um disco com o
grupo
escrevi trilha sonora do teatro trilha
sonora para cinema ganhar uma graninha
o que era um pouco estranho era quem
contratava minha música geralmente era
que gostava de me ouvissem os cientistas
sociais vegetarianos e galera que da
ufmg e eu cantava comunidade e isso não
entrava na minha cabeça
com 16 anos eu descobri que eu sabia
ensinar as rimas
quando eu fiz 18 a minha comunidade me
contratou um programa do estado me
contratou para o da oficina de rima lá
na comunidade e essa oficina durou 15
anos eu rodei a comunidade toda ensino
essas rimas ea gente tinha muita m se
mais de 30 homicídios passaram por lá
alguns ganham grande com isso até hoje
outros fazem outras coisas tiveram a
oportunidade de cantar e está em palcos
maravilhosos e não era sempre que tinha
os pais maravilhosos então fui então
vamos criar nosso movimento também vão
pegar e fazer crer o sarau vira lata que
era um rolê onde reunia jovens poetas
jovens que gostava de poesia terça se
interessando nas ruas de belo horizonte
nem garante que adora no lugar da cidade
e e também esse público vegetariano está
lá mas é era mas era super bem vindo
assim nos 25 sempre respeitou todo mundo
está alguém estava uma coisa própria
improvisar e graças à poesia também
entrei para um grupo de teatro massa
escreveu uma trilha para eles mais tarde
comecei a participar do elenco de palco
e foi bem legal rodar o brasil ganhou
dinheirinho e que aconteceu naquele
momento eu era jovem ainda estava com 23
anos era cabeludo
souter aço na pista com dinheirinho e
era bonitinha seae da oficina
só que eu era triste quando eu voltava
pra mim é quebrada
meu vizinho do lado mãe java que eu
fazia era estranho pra mim e sei lá eu
queria continuar cantando pra essa
galera porque se eu fizesse uma música
mais agressivo eles manchasse do
contexto ele eles iam passar a gostar
também
aí eu retornei pra casinha do meu pai e
me tranquei por lá e fiquei pensando o
que era ser comunidade que eu estava
fazendo ali naquele rolê tinha vizinhos
gente sair eu tenho um vizinho em baixo
do lado do outro atrás e agora na frente
então o povo lá e na casa do lado tinha
fome na casa do outro talvez tinha
espancamento mas algo que fazia isso
tudo é uma coisa só
são as leis das comunidades que é tipo
um chama a polícia não usa droga que
perto da boca num rouba mais uma lei que
é muito universal em qualquer quebrada
que se for no brasil acredito que no
mundo é a lei de cada um na sua função
eu posso não concordar com o que você
faz o que você faz eu vou viver minha
vida o quanto tudo bem vou passar por
ali
está tudo bem e eu parei pra pensar
qualquer a minha função quando eu tava
já retornando ele a minha origem e
naquele momento eu comecei a olhar muito
para as crianças e vi que a minha função
era ser mais do que um artista tele da
quebrada e ele naquele momento eu não
queria mais vínculo com o estado
eu queria ter meu próprio barraco
aluguei um espaço da mesa oficinas do
jeito que eu quisesse que não precisasse
esperar até dez crianças para poder
começar a oficina podia fazer com dois
ou com três e desse espaço tinha muito
livro por conta do sarau de poesia e
biblioteca
a ameaça velada no le porque não tinha
livro agora lê lê lê muito
aí eu fortalecidos exame é quebrado eu
falei ah é e senhores cientistas e não
tem 95 e social a estas estão querendo
me contratar então eles me contratava
aparecerá a cada dois anos só que
levávamos mano tinha um cabelo desse
tamanho assim não chegava às crianças
era muito legal a gente já era um show
só de chegar no espaço aquele tanto de
pessoas junto eu descobri a dança na
minha quebrada eu sou um péssimo
dançarino só que a dança é muito fluente
o baile funk
eu descobri a galera do passinho e essa
galera do passinho foi muito legal
encontrá los porque sério gente eles
lançaram no fit no fit festival
internacional de teatro eles fala para a
mãe que dançou na fit
eles dançaram no palácio das artes fala
para a mãe que dançam na red bull
quero é ver da red bull e uma galera que
destrói muito muito muito
enfim as oportunidades foram acontecendo
a gente gravou uma série para tv com
muitos artistas da quebrada
a gente atende casos de dentista
particular mas eles cedem de graça a
partir desse rolo da favelinha gente
criou o bazar da favelinha música
popular da favelinha o rap da favelinha
o sarau da favelinha eu construí meu
barraco
o meu pai fez só que nossa geração não
quer ter uma casa não quer ter um
apartamento em que morava cada hora no
lugar e minha casa não era pra morar é
lá da favelinha e tem muita gente fala
que lá da favelinha e esse foi meu
barraco que eu construir que eu peguei
fiz mercado porque você fez escolher
porque abandonou todo o ego é legal
demais lá está grande sábio estou agora
aqui em brasília amanhã no rio grande do
sul era massa só que não me completava
e tinha mais esse sistema falido que
tira os possíveis astronautas professora
atleta cantor médico e esse funil que
faz sempre ser só o traficante a
diarista o repositor
nada contra cada um na sua função mas
sobrar só isso para nós é um repositor
na quebrada que é amigo do meu pai eu
considero um tio adão ele entrou como
repositor no supermercado entendeu a
oportunidade gostou da logística virou
caixa virou gerente hoje ele tem um
supermercado da quebrada diarista é a
mãe do leozinho que está por aí
ela teve aqui na ufmg lá na fae naquele
e naquela hora tinha de plantas
medicinais e ela com a dona da cadela
olhou conheço aquilo ali eu penso que
ele começou a dar uma aula de plantas
medicinais para os professores da ufmg e
ela não saber que era medicina que quer
a simpatia mas ela estava ali
representando pela oportunidade
traficante falar que o traficante é
vagabundo que está na pista
mães trabalham 12 por 24 ele sério eles
ganham muito pouco é um dinheiro
imediato e ele resolve algumas questões
comunitárias e humanitárias da quebrada
não estou defendendo volta a falar cada
um na sua função cada um pegue fácil
rolê
outro motivo é que hoje em dia 65% das
crianças do brasil estão na periferia da
doença
daqui 10 anos 50% dos empregos que a
gente tem hoje em dia não existe mais
graças à genética robótica na tecnologia
que é uma coisa do pega aqui mas ele
mandou roubar fazer tudo o que vai
sobressair são os empregos criativos a
criatividade e daqui dez anos quem vai
estar no mercado de trabalho buscando a
oportunidade
são 1 65% da galera da periferia que
hoje em dia tem um metro e meio e se foi
por olho dente por dente rejeição
preconceito você não pode desculpar mas
vocês não vão aguentar porque nós vamos
ter maioria
esse é nosso espaço
é no centro cultural da favelinha que
não comerá da serra hoje em dia a gente
tem 14 oficinas rep
balé inglês passinho artesanato
existência gente tem dez eventos o rap
da favelinha música popular da favelinha
a disputa nervosa que é uma batalha de
passinhos muito legal forró da favelinha
mais de 50 pessoas da comunidade
participaram dessa série de mais de 50
artistas da comunidade se apresentaram
nas edições do rap da favelinha hoje em
dia oito pessoas cumprem medidas
socioeducativas na favelinha eles entram
em conflito com a lei e pagam dentro da
própria comunidade eles têm maior
orgulho do mundo inclusive hoje de manhã
eu usei dois de cobaia falei vem cá que
eu vou apresentar meu teste precisa aqui
se passa seu tempo e três pessoas por
semana tão fazendo tratamento de dente e
além da economia da grana da família que
não vai gastar ali a gente está
desenvolvendo saúde autoestima no
sorriso da galera hoje de manhã a mãe de
uma das crianças uma cirurgia sem que
faça mais de 100 eventos só em 2016
dentro e fora da favelinha e meu
amiguinho pequeno príncipe ali do lado
porque ele diz que os números só
impressiona os adultos os números não
impressionam as crianças
aninha ela não tá nem aí para esses
números
ela é uma criança um incrível que por
ironia do destino tomou três bombas na
primeira série e depois que a favelinha
entrou na vida dela é a melhor aluna do
colégio gente ensinou continha de mais
gente notável vez na história com quem
descobriu o brasil não não não foi
cabral mas não ensinamos nada demais de
menos nem nada saca e é a melhor aluna
do colégio hoje esse show hell's rico
ele é o ator principal dessa série que a
gente gravou e ele um dia virou pra mim
também sim
a lusa é o bob marley pomada menino
nelson mandela que ele fez patarra sua
blusa a ele estou muito pelo direito dos
negros
eu sou negro minha alma negra viaja não
só uma é tudo transparente
ele é incrível
sensacional vocês vão ver ele brilhou
nas telinhas do ano que vem
e pra finalizar eu deixo esse abraço
gostoso e carinhoso da favelinha e eu
pesquisei nutricionais que era
comunidade e ele me disse que a
qualidade daquilo que é comum
nós reunimos hoje em dia todas essas
qualidades que são infinitas
oportunidades e eu queria deixar um
salve para minhas crianças
o mister catra que canta mais ou menos
assim
pintou na sua frente abordando o negão
sebá pergunta se está portando querendo
lhe interrogar o prime marginalizam
sempre só pra variar dizendo favela é
local suspeito então escuta o que eu vou
te falar me respondes e bahá
ah ah ah meu movimento é político social
meu tráfico é cultural meu movimento é
político social meu trato é cultural nem
comigo como traficar cultura que se toca
a peça marca a atividade o negócio é
cantar como traficar cultura dizendo a
gastar essa marca atividade o negócio é
plantar clube quer ouvir em preto em
branco o moço tem sim querendo o seu bem
estar
a favela é socialista me deu o verdão se
de consciência religiosidade e fé em
deus nós temos o coração faz justiça
liberdade e guerras e preconceitos e
emoção quer ouvir quer ouvir como
traficar cultura dizendo que a peça
marca a atividade negócio a plantar
vamos pra ficar futura